i mean vader's obviously the big badass  in the star wars universe i mean him him  going up against sauron would be kind of  fun it became on his side though  wouldn't he would they i think so but  aren't they both like no it's my evil  it's not your ego i think the outside  start side i don't know i need to check  in a multiverse yeah true  when they are starting to do crossovery  stuff right i know marvel's done a lot  of crossover stuff and not wanting to  spoil stuff i did like accidentally  spoil yeah you did a doctor strange  thing for billy the other day which i  thought was brilliant i didn't mean it  no i didn't i actually said have you  seen the new doc strange he said no i  said something happens that's kind of  interesting do you want to know and  billy said yeah go on tell me and then  when i told him he went  out for  harmonize with me and hold me back all  through the night you're shining bright  i'm your hoist the baby you're my pearl